I don't want it to be easy at all in any
way or possible for a man to say that he
is a woman and to have that legal
recognition and legal right no I believe
people should be allowed to live as they
wish to express their gender if they
think that that's what they have
innately as they wish I do not want them
to take our rights there is a huge clash
between the rights of men who identify
as women and actual women I think that
Nicholas sturgeon is a disgrace to women
she is about as feminist
um as
David Cameron she is an absolute
disgrace
as a politician and I just wish that she
would stop her posturing and get off her
perch and recognize that what she's done
is harmful to women and that her Legacy
will be that she put vulnerable women in
more danger than they are already in